[Music]
we have new information about the
discovery of a three hundred and ten
year old Spanish shipwreck carrying
treasure that might be worth up to
seventeen billion dollars the ship was
found with the help of an underwater
robot an unmanned submarine similar to
this one Don Dahler is at the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institute in Cape Cod
Massachusetts where researchers
disclosed the robots role this week Don
good morning good morning this is the
unmanned submersible vehicle the Remus
6,000 it can dive up to depths of four
miles it's loaded with sensors and
cameras and this is part of the team of
researchers who found what may end up
being one of the most valuable
shipwrecks in history these bronze
cannons confirmed the holy grail of
shipwrecks had been found at the bottom
of the Caribbean Sea they're engraved
with dolphins a telltale sign they
belong to the Spanish galleon San Jose
lost more than 300 years ago I just sat
there for about 10 minutes and smiled
Geoff Keighley was alone on his bunk in
the search vessel when he spotted the
cannons I'm not a marine archaeologist
but you know what I can't I know what a
cannon looks like so in that moment I
was the I guess the only person in the
world who knew we'd found this shipwreck
the exact location of the wreckage is
still a secret but it was discovered in
November 2015 off the coast of Cartagena
Colombia its cargo of gold silver and
emeralds could be worth as much as 17
billion dollars today the Reema's 6000
operated by the Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institute in Massachusetts found this
ship almost 2,000 feet below the surface
the underwater robot scanned the sea
floor using long-range sonar then went
back and took pictures of any objects
that seemed out of the ordinary you can
take bigger risks with your technology
and go to places where it wouldn't be
safe or feasible to put a human being
the Remus used the same methods to find
Air France flight 447 which crashed off
the coast of Brazil in 2009 British
warships sunk to San Jose and its crew
of 600 in
17:01 its final moments immortalized by
the painters Samuel Scott for now all of
its treasure remains underwater working
with the Colombian government the Woods
Hole team also found artifacts like
teacups and ceramic jugs everyone's
focused on the treasure aspect the whole
thing is a cultural treasure it's it's a
piece of history that's sitting on the
seafloor that tells a story the actual
location of the shipwreck is still a
secret because there's a legal battle
going on between Spain and Colombia as
to who actually owns the treasure but as
for the folks who found it they say they
don't have a dog in that fight they are
explorers not treasure hunters Gale
still Thank You Don I wouldn't mind a
little reward just a little thank you
for finding it yeah yeah a little
something for the house there off that
sevens not just losers weepers finders
keeper situation at all Thank You Don
Dahler